Hey, this is Radiolab. I'm Jad
Abumrad. Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
The topic is totally tumor. Of course.
It's my line by the way. Oh No. Yeah,
yeah. We've been talking
about tumors. This,
our famous tumors and thus far they've
been really bad. Heritable tumor,
any bad Geary, horrible tumors.
But because we are fair-minded
about everything, even tumors,
let us consider the possibility
that sometimes tumors can be rich,
beautiful and desirable. For example.
Well,
George Malley is an ordinary man who is
about to become extraordinary name as
many mammals as you can in 60 seconds.
How about Alphabetic r Brock, Batman,
Caribou, Dauphine, OHIP hip.
This what is going on in this 1996 movie,
John Travolta plays a guy. If it
gets a brain tumor and a tumor,
the performance makes him
into a genius are quests of
[inaudible] Portuguese language in 20
minutes. Not all of it. Phenomenon.
Learn the accent though too,
where it doesn't give accents,
but, but it does. It does raise a
feel question, which is like can't,
is it possible for a tumor
to create something good?
So we paid a visit to a guy,
a doctor named Orrin Devinsky.
I'm a neurologist at NYU
Langone school of Medicine
and Dr Divinsky has had a
lifelong interest in the
beneficial effects of certain
kinds of brain conditions. Right?
Yeah. I'll just tell you,
I think one of the most fascinating
cases in neurology very quickly,
and this one we were not prepared for.
A gentleman was described who ever since
he was a child would look at safety
pins and have an orgasm at
safety pins at safety pins.
The more shiny and the more
numerous, the safety pin,
the stronger the sexual experience. And
this happened from his pubescent period.
He just safety pins and try them
on. Right. If you were pretty,
he made this association when you looked
at a safety pin, he had an orgasm,
so he got to have been embarrassed by
this. This is worse than being so yeah.
So he would go into pride. He realized
this is not something most people do.
He never talked about it and he did it
in private and then he got married after
the war.
He was honorably discharged and got
married and then started having less sex
with his wife because the safety pin
was much safety pins were much more
enjoyable. Sometimes you just
had to think about a safety pin,
not even hold it up.
So wait,
where are we seriously making the case
that this guy is getting a benefit from
furiously pin obsession.
But I think actually you could say that
the experiences that this guy was having
with those safety pins gave them a kind
of pleasure that maybe is unavailable to
the rest of us from an odd,
odd source, but you know,
pleasures pleasure until says Devinsky.
This fellow began to have seizures,
got admitted to a psychiatric
hospital in London, the Mozley,
one of the big psychiatric
units. They actually got an EEG.
And to make a long story short,
there was a benign tumor.
Oh, right in the part that's
called the temporal lobe,
sort of in the middle of your
head, right behind your eyes.
But they took it out. They
took it out, they took it out,
and they cured him of
his wonderful experience.
So he, uh, he never was able to, he
could look at safety pins all day long,
but he would never again enjoy them
the way he had for his whole life.
How did he feel about that? Um,
I think it was a mixed
blessing as you would imagine.
[inaudible]
well,
I've got blue jeans on sneakers and this
idea that from a tune where you can get
something in the not so good, but also
something good. This is an idea that has,
well, there has been a, a
novel written on this theme.
The title of the book is lying
awake by a friend of mine.
My name is Mark Salzman.
Mark is a writer who lives out
in California and he thought,
I'm going to imagine a nun, our main
characters, sister John of the cross.
This is a woman who had joined a nunnery
because she felt just lonely for a
relationship with God.
Yes. It's just not enough for her
to tell herself. Yes, God is there.
What she longs for is a tangible
sense of God's presence,
a sense that she can really feel
God's presence in her life. And,
um, she,
she begins having what she thinks are
migraine headaches that the regular doctor
that the sisters see tells her that she
seems to be having migraine headaches.
They're coming more and more frequently
and there comes a point when one of
these headaches changes dramatically
and then everything is different.
Everything is different. What's different?
Well, what happens? Shall I read?
Yeah, go ahead. Yeah. You kind of have
to imagine this scene taking place in,
uh, an environment of profound silence.
Okay.
She's in the cloister.
She and one other sister,
they're working on a sewing project.
They're sewing an altar cloth.
One of the pins slipped out of her hand
ringing like a miniature triangle
is it bounced off the floor.
She looked down to the floor and saw that
it looked impossibly distant when she
reached down for the pin,
her hand look strangest of all as
if it belonged to someone else.
The silence in the room came alive
like the words left out of a poem.
[inaudible]
something buried. So deep insider,
but she'd forgotten it was there
rose to the surface sister,
are you not feeling well?
God was present and sister and
his voice was present in her face.
Nothing was changed yet everything was
changed. God is here. She answered,
you were here all along.
Well this is a field goal isn't it?
For someone seeking a spiritual
connection. She has one.
That's right. She was. This is the moment
she's been waiting for all her life.
But there is a problem because
when these things come in,
sorry can we you she has a tumor.
Let's just get the non surprise out of
the way. The show is called totally tumor
famous tumors. Okay. Yes.
She has a meningioma,
a benign tumor,
small about the size of a raisin in
the temporal lobe area of her brain.
Right in the same spot where the
safety pin fellow had his tumor.
So the problem for her is
should I have the tumor removed,
give up the most satisfying and fulfilling
experience of my whole life or should
I sacrifice my health in order to share
with others the experiences that I'm
having. So we thought, well our
Devinsky the doctor we spoke with first.
I think every case is unique and
individual. See patients like this.
This is what he does for that.
So we took the case to him.
Now here's the question.
If a person comes and says,
I'm having what I want
and you are suspicious that what
she also is having is a disease,
what do you do about the patient?
If I knew for sure that the tumor, let's
say was benign and would never grow,
and the only thing that person experienced
was this religious feeling that
they've found extremely enjoyable,
I would say let's do nothing but do
serial scans to make sure nothing grows in
that you're safe.
But in the book, as it happens, the nun
got a little worse. She had a few more
headaches, the more severe,
and they took the tumor out,
the seizure activity stops
[inaudible]
these experiences stopped coming
and she does feel
afterwards a sense of Blah
[inaudible]
she feels as if she sort of tumbled out
of a Himalayan mountain into a muddy
village.
[inaudible]
this is common apparently in patients
after they've been treated. Right.
So my last question then
is really about the,
it seems to me the deepest question
though. All on this case is that, um,
if someone has a very important
and meaningful experience
and you have a sense,
it may be a abnormality, a physical
abnormality that is triggering them,
do you regard them as delusional?
Like there's just the possibility here
that maybe these people are having an
actual conversation. So
yeah, there's no question. Are you
not even considered that? No, I mean,
so side I think the question you asked
and I think you're getting at is could it
truly be that this is God's
Evan knew to speak to us, um,
and people in the late 18 hundreds thought
it was through the right hemisphere.
And that's often where these cases
occur in the right hemisphere.
So it may be that that's right.
It's the more emotional hemisphere and
when things are in a perturbed state,
you may be more receptive to
experiencing spiritual things.
And I think there probably is some
physiologic basis that allows you to tune
into a broader world and maybe some
states of neurologic dysfunction allow you
to harmonize or tune in or receive
those messages so to speak.
In which case then your tumor or your
epilepsy would be the window or the
conduit. Right. I do feel like I
need to place an asterix right here,
like we are talking about
a tumor in the end. Well,
but understand that every feeling,
every thought you have comes
from cells in your brain.
Yeah.
Any of those cells can produce a glorious
experience than the experienced stands
on its own and sometimes in
very well documented cases.
These are extraordinarily profound,
desirable thing. They're often hard to
put into words. Have you tried, I mean,
when you, I mean people,
you know Destro Yefsky,
he's probably the most articulate person
with epilepsy who's had a religious
experience and who wrote
down what he experienced.
I don't have the quote in front of me,
but it's, you know, this Felicity, this,
this a feeling I get
for several moments he was quoted to
say that I would experience such joy as
would be inconceivable in ordinary life.
I would feel the most complete harmony
in myself and in the whole world.
And this feeling was so strong and sweet
that for a few seconds of
such bliss, I would give
[inaudible]
10 or more years of my life
even my whole life.
[inaudible]
hi.